authorities in the Philippines have
apologized after images such as these
became public showing the state of under
preparedness for the Southeast Asian
Games the games officially opened this
weekend and are being hosted by the
Philippines complaints range from
incomplete construction to airport
delays insufficient food for athletes
not enough rooms and so on here's more
on what the organizing committee called
cote inefficiencies or Mis coordination
the Philippines is hoping the 2019
Southeast Asian Games would signal the
country's readiness to host the larger
Asian Games in 2030 based on the Iraqi
opening days of this year's tournament
2030 seems like a pipe dream some
preliminary competitions have already
kicked off with the games officially
starting on Saturday but construction
work continues as the list of complaints
from visiting athletes and
administrators piles ever higher with
long waits for shuttle services and a
lack of accommodations many participants
have been forced to sleep on floors
Indonesia's weightlifting and football
teams even decided to book their own
hotels instead of relying on
accommodations provided by the hosts
botched preparations but a strain on
athletes already coping with a crowded
schedule no I was pretty upset
first guy here with you know three hours
to wait in the airport and then eight
hours waiting into theater rooms and the
guy sleeping on the floor and you know
that adds up in the tournament like this
the logistical chaos has brought
unwanted negative attention on the
tournament and put organizers under
widespread criticism and that unwanted
attention has spilled out onto social
media one local newscaster posted this
video on Twitter of a slightly puzzling
look inside one of the women's bathrooms
that has not one toilet but two next to
each other without any divider in
between but that's not all as well as
inadequate facilities for athletes and
others the sporting venues themselves
seem woefully unprepared
on social media user noticed a problem
or two with this skating rink supposedly
for the speed skating event it's still
unfinished
dirty and has not been cordoned off from
the public then there was the first
football match between Myanmar and
Malaysia which kicked off without a
scoreboard luckily with a 1-1 draw it
was easy to keep track of the goals
unhappy volunteers have been chiming in
as well
this user posted a complaint by a man
who says he was given nothing to drink
during a tiring and chaotic 8-hour shift
only to be handed this morsel after he
had finished let us know what you think
of this story our big sporting events
such as the Southeast Asian Games too
big and unwieldy to organise in it to
organize efficiently go to our YouTube
page and write in the comments below